[Music]
I think especially here in the heart of
Silicon Valley where organizations pride
themselves on their innovation and their
creativity if any place were to be able
to take advantage of a diverse workforce
and the creativity that's associated
with that diversity it should be here
and yet time and time again we see
evidence that Silicon Valley firms are
in fact very homogeneous mostly male and
mostly white we don't have a lot of
leaders who are female or people of
color but let's focus on a minute on
females because if we're ever going to
be successful in diversity that should
be the dimension on which we are most
successful because we have the most of
them right 51% of the population so what
happens well turns out that we actually
have a bias if we think leader too many
of us think male and if you think male
we think leader but in fact there's some
very interesting research that's coming
out in the last couple of years that
suggests that that perspective may be
changing one of the most favorite
studies is a study that was done is
actually a meta-analysis so they got a
whole bunch of other studies ninety nine
different studies and they looked at
leaders who evaluated themselves and
whose subordinates evaluated them and
they came up with a very interesting set
of results what they found was that
while male leaders evaluated themselves
as more effective than did their female
counterparts the subordinates of these
leaders evaluated the female leaders as
more effective than they did their male
counterparts and this was true except in
two industries government and the
military now what's unique about those
two industries those two industries are
extremely hierarchical so women were
perceived by their subordinates
as better leaders in organizations or in
industries where it was a more
collaborative form of leadership other
researchers have found that one of the
ways to actually get a more effective
group is to increase the number of women
and it turns out there's actually a very
high correlation between the number of
women in a group and the bill T of that
group to be innovative and creative the
first contender may be that there simply
aren't enough qualified women a second
contender may be non conscious or
implicit bias a third contender may be
that the criteria by which we hire
changes depending on who we're looking
at and the fourth criteria may be that
in fact what happens is we get women
into the organization we don't move them
up because we change the criteria by
which we judge their performance this is
an interesting perspective because it
suggests that were there enough
qualified women of course we would hire
them but what's interesting to observe
given that statement is that since 1988
more women have graduated from US
universities than have men and in 2010
for example the majority of people
receiving undergraduate degrees master's
degrees and PhDs were women and so it
turns out that a lot of people who are
getting these advanced degrees happen to
be female so maybe it's not that they're
not enough qualified women maybe what's
happening is we're not seeing these
women as qualified now maybe that's
because of implicit bias right we have
biases about what we think would be the
correct person to have in this job and
so my favorite example of how powerful
this implicit bias is is some work by
golden and arouse
what they did was they went to Symphony
Orchestra's who were conducting
auditions and they said we'd like you to
conduct your auditions behind a curtain
now this didn't seem a big deal because
think about a Symphony Orchestra what
does a symphony orchestra care about the
quality of the music who cares if the
violin that is so awesome is being
played by a male or a female this isn't
relevant and in fact certainly their
financial model does not require that
they have all males are all females it's
irrelevant it's the quality of the music
that the patrons will pay for and so
what happened so they did their
auditions behind a curtain which hid the
race and gender of the musician and when
they did that women were 50% more likely
to move up in the audition process and
250 percent more likely to gain a seat
in the orchestra so while there seems to
be no economic incentive as to why we
have this bias it may be that there is a
psychological impediment that stops us
from seeing from hearing the music of
women as being equal or sometimes better
than the music of men wouldn't that be
awesome if we could actually just judge
people on their performance rather than
filtering that performance through their
notion of gender and what is appropriate
or not appropriate
well actually an organization here in
the valley did that what they did is
they had an online application process
and the application process required
that people engage in activities that
were representative of what they would
be doing in the organization and before
they judged who they would actually
bring in for the interview they stripped
all of the information about race or
gender
from the applicants they just had their
performance and when the curtain was
pulled back over 60% of the top
performers were people of color or women
there's an organization here called
speak with a geek which is a tech
recruiting organization and they did an
interesting experiment they sent out
resumes to their clients 5,000 resumes
and the clients review those resumes and
then sent back request to interview
folks and when they did this with full
information about the race and gender of
the applicants fewer than 5% of the
women were called back for interviews
they took those same five thousand
resumes and sent them out again but they
stripped off identifying information
about race and gender and in that case
54% of the resumes that were asked to be
brought in for interviews were resumes
of women the difference is huge
[Music]
oftentimes we look at the candidate and
decide what it is we want and adjust the
criteria to who we were looking at there
was a wonderful study that was done by
researchers who posed to people who were
doing recruiting for a traditional male
job a police chief and an advantage
they're looking at candidates they asked
the recruiters what do you care more
about and it turns out there were two
dimensions that really came through
one was experience and one was education
and so in fact these recruiters
privileged education over experience so
they sent out two Vedas the Vedas were
exactly the same except that video
number one from Bob
had more education than experience and
from Barbara she had more experience
than education
and true to what they said they selected
Bob over Barbara then what the
researchers did is they switched the
names so now Barbara has more education
and Bob has more experience and guess
what the recruiters preferred now you
guessed it experience the solution here
of course is to establish clear criteria
before you begin the interview process
but that's just half the job you've got
to make sure that you actually have the
correct criteria so consider for example
the challenge that Carnegie Mellon
University had when they attempted to
improve the gender balance of their
computer science major they were having
a very small percentage of women being
applying for and being admitted to their
computer science program now as they
reassessed the criteria by which they
judged whether you could be admitted or
not one of the criteria was a lot of
experience in computers which at first
blush seems quite reasonable computer
major you should understand computers
but let's take that apart just a little
bit so if I were majoring in medicine
how much experience would I have to have
in a medical setting before I could be a
medical major or how much engineering
experience do I need before I became an
engineer or how much teaching experience
what I need before I became an educator
you see what happens is is that we
actually help people figure out how to
be a doctor an engineer a teacher that's
what graduate and undergraduate
education is all about so the percentage
of women went from 7% to 42% with just
that one change
[Music]
research was done looking at
organizations in fact they were there
were three tech organizations and one
consulting firm and they and the
researchers got access to all of the
performance reviews from those four
companies and they did an analysis of
how did those did those reviews differ
by gender and if so how what they found
was is that the majority of root of the
reviews of males as compared to females
actually associated the review with a
tangible business-related outcome so the
men were told how well or poorly they
did on something that mattered to the
organization a real business outcome
what was interesting is for the females
they were mostly given vague feedback
you're doing okay you're not doing well
maybe you need to have this but they did
there was no precision in that feedback
and of the women who were given more
precise feedback what was also true was
it was mostly about their communication
style and this is the fact the way that
I think is most telling in looking at
all of these performance reviews
seventy-five percent of the individuals
in these reviews who were judged to be
aggressive and that aggression came out
in their performance review for women
seriously of all the people in these
organizations the problem they were
having with aggression was because of
the females or maybe it's because we
have a different standard what we
adjudicate as aggression in women versus
aggression in men there was a study in a
medical school that looked at the
letters of recommendation for their
students who were going out into
residency positions and they found very
interesting results number one the
letters of the male students were much
longer
than those of the female and the letters
of the male students talked about their
accomplishments and their potential
while the letters of the female students
talked about their personality think
about an organization whose culture is
strongly committed to meritocracy and
data-driven decisions you'd think in
that type of organization a lot of these
problems would go away but it turns out
just the opposite is true
when an organization has such a strong
adherence to meritocracy and data-driven
decisions and there are managers and
leaders because of their association
with the organization or by explicit
statement agree with that it turns out
those folks are actually more likely to
discriminate against women and people of
color in their compensation decisions
why it may sound paradoxical but it
turns out that this is called the moral
licensing effect so have you ever been
in a situation what happens to me all
the time I go work out and then because
I've worked out really hard I now give
myself permission to have that piece of
chocolate cake
that's called moral licensing I've
already proved that I'm a good person I
worked out and now I can eat my cake if
I'm a manager in an organization that
has such a strong notion of meritocracy
then by definition of being in that
organization I lower my guard about
whether or not my individual decisions
are consistent with that because this is
part of this organization it's our DNA
so of course we focus on merit and data
this is the problem organizations and
individuals need to be eternally
vigilant we cannot just assume that that
problem has passed that we have solved
the problem because we care about data
or that we care about meritocracy we
have to assess are the decisions that
I'm making consistent with the data not
my perceptions not my biases but the
data and more importantly do I every day
make sure that I actually broaden the
potential of who might I might consider
for jobs or the narrow am I taking
responsibility when I see good
performance do I let other people know
or do I just let that good performance
speak for itself
assuming of course everyone else will
see it
so what is my contribution to the lack
of diversity in my organization and
that's something that every one of us
needs to think about because it is up to
us to change
[Music]